bobsaget's wife kelly rizzo pays a sweet
homage to her late husband in the
upcoming netflix special dirty daddy the
bob saget tribute and while there are
sure to be tears bob's good friends and
fellow comedians jim carrey jeff ross
chris rock john stamos and many more are
all there to provide tons of laughter
and light-hearted moments uh yeah a
celebration of bob's life in comedy
seems like the best way to do it here's
a preview before it arrives on netflix
tomorrow see ya
bob wasn't something that was taken away
from us it was something that was given
to us i hope everybody here either have
bob is a friend like that or someday has
a friend like bob kelly do you want to
come up
keep it
the most short thing to him was
belonging to this club to this group to
being a comedian welcome to the bob
super spreader everybody
we're coming to see you bob
[Applause]
he actually told me once that he was
gonna donate his penis to science and
actually last week kelly got a letter
and it said dear mrs saggitt we think we
could do better
you made people laugh
you made people feel loved
you made people money
i think it's sad that
had to die to get jim carrey back on
stage
every one of us up here swear that we
were his best friend you know i think
that's the mark of
a liar you know
when i read my last text from bob i said
i love you so much i will say that god
gave me the brother that i wanted i said
well you have a lot of god-given
brothers but i'm first right and he said
mayor is an amazing friend but he's more
fair weather you're always there so
you're number one
he accepted us and acceptance is the
boring part of love but it's just as
important you created a cathedral of
love bob saget
thank you
for the gift of bob saget